a mission to get foreign nationals out
of Wuhan as quickly as possible as this
German airforce plane departed from
Cologne Airport it was one of a number
of countries that intensified efforts to
get its citizens out of the city at the
center of the outbreak is leaking its
allure there are more than 100 people
none of whom are infected there are also
no suspected cases amongst these people
in order to guarantee the safety of the
people in Germany evacuees will be
Florentine for two weeks to German army
base to ensure that none of the evacuees
is infected on the doctrine stats Berger
at least half a dozen people in Germany
were confirmed to have tested positive
for the virus and the pressure to
contain it is urgent in the UK on Friday
the first cases of the illness appeared
the same day as the British government
transported its citizens back from the
lockdown region aboard the plane are the
110 evacuees who managed to make it out
of Wuhan but there are still many other
foreign nationals trapped in the city
unable as of yet to get out those who
arrived were immediately taken away by
coach to a health facility in the
northwest of England they will now spend
the next two weeks in quarantine
monitored for any signs of the disease
and if any one of them developed
symptoms they will be taken to one of
four specialized hospitals for treatment
with a vaccine still months away from
being remotely ready countries are
focusing on containment and management
of any outbreaks masks are becoming
prevalent in high-risk areas such as
airports as a threat of the virus is
still to be assessed sonya de jager al
jazeera Brize Norton England